Ana: Hoy llegamos al punto en que el edificio liberal empieza a crujir. No porque no haya construido cosas valiosas, sino porque dejó una pregunta sin responder: ¿quién protege al trabajador?
Mateo: Esa pregunta se llama cuestión social. Pobreza, accidentes laborales, enfermedad, vejez sin protección, jornadas extenuantes, trabajo infantil, ausencia de negociación colectiva. El mercado no resolvía eso por sí solo.
Ana: En Costa Rica aparece primero de forma mutualista: sociedades de artesanos, ayuda en enfermedad o muerte, solidaridad de oficio. Todavía no es sindicalismo moderno, pero ya es organización popular.
Mateo: En el Caribe bananero el cuadro es más duro. Trabajadores asalariados frente a una gran empresa extranjera, con jornadas largas, vivienda precaria y servicios limitados. Las huelgas bananeras muestran que el enclave también era un conflicto social.
Ana: En 1931 aparece el Partido Comunista con Manuel Mora Valverde. Su papel es clave: organiza trabajadores, participa electoralmente y empuja una agenda laboral que el liberalismo había postergado.
Mateo: Y al mismo tiempo crece el catolicismo social. Desde la Rerum Novarum, la Iglesia critica tanto el capitalismo sin límites como el socialismo ateo. En Costa Rica esa corriente llega a figuras como Jorge Volio y Rafael Ángel Calderón Guardia.
Ana: Me fascina que el camino hacia las Garantías Sociales no sea lineal ni ideológicamente puro. Comunistas, socialcristianos e Iglesia católica terminan colaborando en los años cuarenta.
Mateo: Es una alianza insólita: Calderón Guardia, Manuel Mora y el arzobispo Víctor Manuel Sanabria. En otros países habrían sido enemigos irreconciliables; aquí encontraron un terreno común: proteger socialmente a la población trabajadora.
Ana: Calderón Guardia venía con formación socialcristiana europea, y su gobierno coincide con la Segunda Guerra Mundial. En ese contexto se crea la Universidad de Costa Rica en 1940.
Mateo: La UCR no es un detalle académico. Unifica escuelas profesionales, crea una universidad pública con autonomía y le da al país una institución de cultura superior. El derecho, la medicina, la economía y la educación empiezan a dialogar de otra forma.
Ana: En 1941 se crea la Caja Costarricense de Seguro Social. Ahí la idea cambia radicalmente: enfermedad, invalidez, maternidad, vejez y muerte dejan de ser solo tragedias privadas; pasan a ser riesgos socialmente asegurados.
Mateo: Luego vienen las Garantías Sociales de 1942 y 1943: derecho al trabajo, salario mínimo, jornada máxima, vacaciones, sindicalización, huelga, contratación colectiva, protección a la mujer y al menor trabajador.
Ana: Y el Código de Trabajo de 1943 organiza todo eso como derecho cotidiano. Principio protector, irrenunciabilidad de derechos, contrato realidad, continuidad de la relación laboral. Es una nueva gramática jurídica.
Mateo: Lo crucial es que la reforma social no destruye propiedad privada ni mercado. Los limita, los civiliza, los rodea de obligaciones. El trabajador deja de ser solo parte débil de un contrato y pasa a ser sujeto constitucionalmente protegido.
Ana: También hay una enseñanza política: las etiquetas no explican todo. Comunista, católico, socialcristiano; esas palabras pesaban muchísimo, pero el contexto y los liderazgos permitieron una convergencia concreta.
Mateo: La reforma de los cuarenta transforma el Estado liberal en Estado con responsabilidades sociales. No es socialismo revolucionario; es capitalismo con regulación social, seguro social, educación pública superior y derechos laborales.
Ana: Por eso, cuando llegue la Constitución de 1949, no partirá de cero. Recogerá estas conquistas y las pondrá en el centro del pacto constitucional.
Mateo: La siguiente taza será amarga y decisiva: guerra civil, abolición del ejército, Tribunal Supremo de Elecciones y una Constitución que intenta reconciliar libertad liberal con justicia social.